gabriel matzneff qui est en face de vous
si un vrai vieille ta professeur quand
même d'éducation sexuelle c'est quand
même ça ils riaient de mac c'est parce
que je donne volontiers des cours et en
payant de sa personne
pourquoi vous êtes vous spécialiser dans
les lycéennes et les mines est au dessus
de 20 ans on voit que ça ne vous
intéresse plus mon cher c'est la
réciprocité aussi qui est vrai je n'ai
jamais eu aucun succès auprès des femmes
de 25 30 et plus des femmes installés
dans la vie j'aime bien aussi et je
trouve que quand on a dans sa vie
quelqu'un qui n'est pas encore durci par
la vie une femme qui a déjà eu beaucoup
d'hommes dans sa vie beaucoup d
illusions parce que comme les hommes
sont en général soit des égoïsmes des
lâches
les femmes ne peuvent que se durcir
n'est ce pas et donc je préfère l'avoir
dans ma vie des gens qu'ils ont encore
durci qui sont plus gentils une fille de
très jeunes et plutôt plus gentille
même si elle devient très vite
hystérique et aussi folle que quand il
sera paysagé marisa bête gelé connu
quand elle avait 15 ans la haye la nana
20 ou 22 candidats se livrent elle est
toujours dans ma vie c'est pas lui c'est
durable
vous êtes quand même un collectionneur
de minettes et est alors par exemple
vous faites des bilans de temps en temps
forme éblouissante donc et mes amours en
témoigne la conquête en trois jours
consécutifs de trois inconnus dont deux
vierge marie agnès mode et 7 brigitte s
avec qui j'ai fait l'amour toute les
façon quasi sans interruption moi je
crois que je suis je vis actuellement
sur une autre planète
parce que j'arrive d'un continent un
certain nombre de choses auxquelles on
croit moi monsieur matzneff me semble
pitoyable ce que je ne comprends pas
c'est que dans ce pays et je le
comprends parce que la littérature à une
sorte d'aura ici c'est que dans ce pays
la littérature entre guillemets sert
d'alibi à ce genre de confidences parce
que ce que nous raconte monsieur
matzneff dans un livre qu'il quitterait
son milieu parce que parce que la
répétition est extrêmement nuit je lis
finit par le tombé des mains
c'est là qu'est ce qui va devenir
agressive comme ça dans le 6/9 nous
racontent qu'ils se de mise des petites
filles de 14 ans 15 ans que ces petites
filles sont folles de lui
on sait bien que des petit fils filles
peuvent être folle d'un monsieur qui a
une certaine aura littéraire d'ailleurs
on sait que les vieux monsieur attire
les petits enfants avec des bonbons
monsieur massenet
lui les attire avec sa réputation mais
ce que l'on sait aussi c'est que ces
petites filles
ce que l'on ne sait pas c'est comment
ces petites filles de 14 ou 15 ans n'est
ce pas qui ont été non seulement 6,8
mais qui ont subi ce que l'on appelle
dans les rapports entre des adultes et
les jeunes un abus de pouvoir comment
s'en sortent eux tels ces petites filles
après coup moi je crois que c'est petit
fils à son son flétri et la plupart
d'entre elles flétri peut-être pour le
restant de leurs jours
heureusement pour vous un homme courtois
parce que vraiment je trouve insensé de
parler d'eux comme vous le venait de le
faire que vous vous n'avez pas lu mon
livre vous l'avez feuilleter dans ce
livre il y à des rencontres d'amour de
séduction réciproque
je n'ai je ne suis pas du tout je suis
le contraire d'un macho d'un type qui
force qui que ce soit faire quoi que ce
soit est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup la plupart
de ces jeunes filles d'ailleurs n'en
paient pas une jeune fille de 14 ans il
a des jeunes filles qu'il y en a que
deux ou trois ans puis sont tout à fait
l'âge de vivre des amours elle tombe sur
un homme qui n'est pas un monstre de
laideur qui est relativement les traits
qui est un assez bien élevé qui peut
être très gentil et qui fait les rend
très heureuse et je vous interdit de
porter des jugements de ce genre de
jugement
d'abord parce qu'un d'yves c'est une
écriture c'est un ton c'est un univers
je suis est donc d'abord portant un
jugement sur un livre d'abord savoir si
cette année d'un écrivain si c'est un
beau livre la ligue on ne peut pas
servir des soli même à la littérature
[Musique]